all right casey
hi casey where did you go where are you
from originally i'm from salisbury
maryland
is that near baltimore yeah okay tell me
about your family growing up
um
well i grew up with um
my mom and i um my father was in my life
for like maybe like um
like the first like couple years then
um he started doing um crack
and so he was mostly strung out on crack
most of my life
yeah so i didn't really get to see him
that much like kind of
off and on so mainly my mom raised me
how was childhood with mom
um well she had a like a lot of
different guys in and out of her life so
um
it was definitely like me being
transgender it was like
um
it was really hard for me because um my
stepfather was abusive so
he used to like hit me and stuff and
choke me
physical abuse yeah physical abuse you
know um
and you know also like just like um
verbal abuse too
um and you know it wasn't just that my
house was also like at my school like i
would have to constantly deal with like
all that at my school and then come home
and deal with it so it was just like a
lot of like
emotions that i just like would bottle
up and just like
not have anywhere to really put that
like emotional trauma that i was
experiencing so i just like really just
stay i was really a loner kind of but
why do you think you were a target for
the
huh why do you think you were a target
for the abuse
at school oh for being um
gay
and transgender so
well i always knew i was transgender but
at the time i wasn't my mom wouldn't
allow me to transition she told me that
she didn't want me to like start my
transition until i was like out away
from like her house like out of her
house so i wasn't really allowed to
start i had a really i i um had to like
buy hormones offline and sneak it and
like do a lot of stuff when they weren't
there like dress up and stuff when when
my parents were home and my sister
wasn't home so you feel like you were
always this way yeah you were born this
way yeah
there was no event in your childhood
that caused it
no um
no there wasn't really i was never like
molested or anything so it was nothing
like that
you finished high school yeah
barely my mom helped me so
yeah i got like my like final years like
i was it was really hard for me to like
go to school because i was constantly
dealing with like a lot like because i
transitioned when i was like 16 so
like i switched schools to a different
school so i was hoping no one would know
me but
it's like um
you know like it like on the first day
it was like really stressful i like i i
felt like i had to leave school like i
was i was just so like scared like
because
i didn't have my name changed yet so
like everyone would call me like my
birth name my boy name so it's just like
it was just really hard like being a
woman and then like so being called like
boy
like names and stuff so
yeah and like um i was like the only
like transgender person in that school
so i felt like a lot of the students
didn't know how to relate to me or like
to react to like they're being like a
transgender person so
like yeah
you came to california at what age
um i was 25 when i came here oh yeah
i'm 27.
so you've been here a couple of years
have you found it easier for you in
california
actually um the weather is nice um
[Music]
um since i've been here i've i've
started using heavy drugs so um
i don't think that's like i don't know i
it's hard it's hard to say because i
didn't when i came here i wanted to be
an actress
and
like
i just started hanging out with like the
wrong crowd i guess and like doing drugs
and so being homeless
so just like i would just like rely on
guys from like online dating or
something and like stay at their house
and like for a couple days
and so and then they would eventually
get tired of me of course so i have to
move on to the next person and that's
how you're getting by now um yeah that's
that's basically how i'm getting by now
i have this one guy who i've known for
like since july who i've been staying
with he's been helping me but sometimes
we get into fights and stuff so
but he does like drugs really heavily so
you know me trying to like
not do drugs um it's really hard because
like
everyone i hang around
it's like it's all around me i feel like
i don't know i don't know where what to
do really
it just seems like that's the thing here
and what is your drug crystal meth um
well i've tried pretty much every drug
um recently i've just been doing crystal
meth and um
yeah just crystal meth really and coke
and stuff
pills xanax and you'll get money for
those by yeah oh entertaining men yeah
sex work yeah how is that for you is it
um
i like it
um i like the i think it's kind of like
an eagle boost almost like i kind of
like get a thrill off of it
but
you know after like i've like seen like
i mean i can see like like five or six
guys in a day and then
it's just after that there's like an
empty feeling like
you know a lot of these guys have like
wives and they go home to their house
and stuff and it's like and i'm just
like
having sex with these guys and it's like
i'm having like a really emotional
connection with them and then it's just
like it's over after they like you know
get whatever they're looking for you
know so it's like i have like the money
but i mean you know
there's like an empty feeling at the end
of the day sometimes
yeah would you just are you lonely would
you describe yourself as lonely um yeah
i spend most of my time alone honestly
um
i don't really like to hang out with a
lot of people because like
just like i've been in fights and stuff
with like other transgender people
and like jealousy issues and
sometimes like i feel like it's better
if i spend my time alone so i'll go like
three or four days just like sitting in
the house like or wherever secluded
somewhere
and then um
i'll come out and it'll be fun
people will give me some attention so
it makes me feel good and then
i'll just hide away for a couple more
days do you have any friends
in your life no yes i don't
which i want some but it's really
complicated to make friends
sometimes
especially in this life you know
and
trying to you know pick choose my
friends who
are not doing drugs like most of the
girls i know transgender are
you know they do drugs they're drug
addicts so
yeah
do you feel like you were accepted
as you know by your family you were
young um
at first i wasn't accepted like they
were really mean to me but then after
that they started to come around but
it's like
it's never it never
is on the level as it was before i
transitioned and it always like comes in
like like comes like in the back of my
head like oh if i wasn't trans i'd
probably like have like a deeper
connection with these people you know
so it just makes me really feel like
really emotional about it because it's
like i don't want to think that but it's
just sometimes i do
sometimes i think that and it just like
bothers me because it's like i'm not
gonna change who i am
just so that like they'll accept me like
that's not fair to me
it's like if i lose myself
but i gain them it's like i really you
know it's like i lose myself at the end
of the day
it's like you're choosing this
lifestyle to
be defiant you're just this is just the
way you are yeah yeah like i'm not
trying to be defined or anything
but
you know i think that um like they say
they're supportive but
financially like i could really use the
help and like
if and if they have like money it's like
i don't understand why they don't
help me you know like why don't you guys
help me if you know i'm struggling
like why didn't why not help me i don't
get it if i had the money like they have
i would
help them in like a heartbeat you know
so
and living on skid row is going to be
hard right
yeah it's hard out here what kind of
stuff has happened to you
um
[Music]
just um
a lot of guys um
you know i'll see them and like they'll
um
have like had guys give me fake money
before
so it's like i had sex with them and
then i come to find out the money was
fake so it was like um
it almost feels like i'm getting raped
almost but not really it's like not
forcefully done it's just like
almost like tricking me i get tricked a
lot
like out i'll get in guys cars and
they'll like touch on me and stuff and
then
come to find out they don't have any
money
so it's like
a lot of dead ends out here
but
do you feel like there's any options for
you
options can you can you go to another
you know
part of the country part of the city and
find a life that's that's better for you
um
i don't know i've i've i started sex
work when i was like um 19 so
um
i don't really know was it was was it
similar for you back in
maryland
um experience
well i was i was back in maryland i was
staying with my sister we like had an
apartment together
but we started to get fight we started
we would fight a lot about stupid stuff
like you know so
yeah
what emotions do you go through
um i go through a lot of depression
because um anxiety like because a lot of
guys like i'll walk down the street and
they'll like cat call
or they'll be like oh that's a man or
they'll be like you know just saying
[ __ ] or like just like stuff and like
sometimes like i'll look at their faces
and like just like looking at the cars
like the way they look at me it's just
it just makes me feel really
uncomfortable like it's hard sometimes
to like walk out in public because i
just i feel like just like
just like dirty stares and stuff and and
like my anxiety and depression sometimes
i just cannot get out of bed like it's
hard for me yeah i think some days you
just want to stay inside and not go
anywhere yeah do you have a place to
stay usually or
um well this guy
he's helping me right now with the hotel
um but
before him i was um
living in a tent
so
yeah it's gonna be a hard lifestyle yeah
it was really hard i wanted to kill
myself but i was like
i just gotta get through this and then
eventually i i think that um
things will turn around but it's just
i've been here three years it's like i
don't
i don't know
you've been using drugs like crystal
meth for how long
um i started using crystal meth probably
like after a year of me being here
so has your life gotten better or worse
since you've
um
worse
i've lost stuff
you know most times i live out of a
suitcase
so i'll like leave my suitcase somewhere
and then i'll come back and it's gone so
yeah
yeah you sleep on crystal meth huh when
you sleep taking crystal meth you sleep
for like a day right
um when i take crystal meth yeah um
sometimes i'll like not sleep for a
couple days and then and then when you
finally do sleep i'll crash and then
like and you get robbed uh-huh
yeah sometimes yeah
yeah good rub i'll lose stuff you know
you do feel misunderstood as a trans
woman misunderstood um yes i feel very
misunderstood i feel like people look at
me and they think i'm a joke
or they'll like laugh like and i'm just
like what's so funny
i don't get like i don't understand why
people look at me and like they like
feel the need to like laugh or feel
uncomfortable or they'll be like oh you
have like nice hair or oh you have nice
makeup or nice clothes but
it's like all superficial they're not
really trying to be
close to me they're just
i don't know
what was what was the best memory of
your life
um
the best memory of my life
probably my probably when i was a little
boy
when i felt really loved by my family
and i felt like everything was safe and
like
you know but like you know as i've
gotten older like and i transitioned
it's like
um
i don't really feel the same type of
love i mean i don't know
i have my moments of where i feel like i
love my family and then
like i'll go through
things and i'm like wait is that love
even real like i don't get it you know
[Music]
so it's really confusing
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about in your life
i'm afraid of catching hiv
um i'm afraid of dying i don't want to
die yet
um
i'm afraid of like never making out of
um this like lifestyle i'm like really
terrified that i'm gonna like
because i'm trying so hard but it's like
it just feels like like a lot of like it
just feels like every time i try to come
up like there's something that pulls me
back down whether it's drugs or whether
it's guys or
you know
and with the lifestyle i live it's like
i have like a lot of anxiety and
depression so
i've tried medication
i don't like i don't like how it makes
me feel um sometimes i do xanax to help
my anxiety but
that leads to me doing crystal meth and
drinking
and coke
and the medications you've been
prescribed for are for like
depression
yeah they gave me um antidepressants
but i didn't feel like
it really helped i felt like it was just
making me kind of feel weird
yeah do you feel like
living the way you do has made you
stronger or
how has it changed um yeah it's made me
a lot stronger um
you know it's made me not care so much
what people say because it's like every
day i walk out like people say stuff so
it's like you know like it's like you
know sometimes i just have to suck it up
and just go out there because it's like
if not then i'm gonna be
you know i'm gonna be
like if i don't leave my house then i'm
just gonna you know end up broke and
like back on the streets again you know
living in a tent
depressed
what do you dream of in your life do you
i dream of being um a celebrity
and living in a nice house i want to get
married one day i hope that that happens
um
i want to continue with my transition
and hopefully get more surgeries
okay i would like to get a sex change um
i i deal with like a lot of like
body and like
mind like
like it's like differences like it's
like i feel like you know i want to be
like this like and stuff but it's like
i feel like i can't really go to the
beach
because you know i still have like this
you know i haven't had this the surgery
um so i just it makes me feel really
uncomfortable like you're referring to
is srs what is srs um basically a sex
change where they turn your penis into a
vagina
and you can do that in the united states
um yeah you can it's cheaper if you go
like to thailand and stuff though
but
i don't know i don't have a passport or
anything how common is that surgery in
the trans community
um
i think it's not very common yeah i've
seen the majority of
the trans women that i've interviewed
have
have not had this special equipment yeah
yeah
what was your worst experience as a
child
um
i was touched by my sister
she would like touch me and that really
made me feel really uncomfortable with
my body and like my body because i felt
like i couldn't tell anybody or say
anything
and it was huh
i was like six
and like she would touch he would like
touch me and stuff and like
um and like i would feel really
uncomfortable but i felt like i couldn't
do anything i felt like powerless it was
so weird i don't know
but yeah that was probably one of the
most traumatic things that have happened
to me
i went to jail for a year
so
that was really going to jail for what
um for assault with a deadly weapon
against you
um it was against some woman i was like
at this rehab facility because i broke
my foot
and
i broke my foot because i was high on
crystal meth then like i was hop i was
like climbing over fences i thought i
was paranoid i thought like cops were
after me but really it was just me being
paranoid so i went to a rehab center
from the hospital
and
i was doing at first i wasn't i was
pretty sober but
um i was like i have my dealer's number
so i called him and got some xanax
because i was feeling really anxious um
with the other
residents like it was mostly like all
guys so and that's another thing would
be being transgender it's like most
facilities i go to are going to be for
men
so it's like
me being transgender it's like a lot of
these men want to have sex with me they
want to touch me they want to talk to me
and it's just like
i just feel like almost like i don't
have a way out it's like
you know it would be safer for you to go
to a women's facility
um i don't i don't know i don't know
i've never been to a woman's facility
and
like hypothetically like you would think
like okay it would be safer for me but
i've never actually been
in like an all woman's facility you know
um
but it seems like a lot of times like
sometimes like women can be like
aggressive physically um sexually as
well
a women's facility would
probably have the issue you know you're
still a man
yeah they're they're they're not most of
the places they say okay you're not we
can't let you in here because you know
you're technically still you have like a
male part so
you don't say that either way
yeah i really feel like i don't fit in
either way
yeah it's really weird i don't like that
feeling i feel like
i don't like that feeling i don't know
and even with the bathroom like i feel
like
like when i go in the women's room i
almost feel like uncomfortable because
i'm like
when you go to a public washroom you go
to the men's or women's
um
for a long time i just went to the
women's
um
i've been i've been in the men's room a
couple of times just because i wanted to
see what it would be like
and um i don't know
it i mean a couple of times i've went
into like the men's room and the guys
were like uh this is like the men's room
are you doing here
you know so i'm like um
you know so but
okay so what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
in my life the most important thing i've
learned um
i don't know um
not to um
give myself away for free
to men because it's like
i've been tricked a lot like i've like
thought these like guys wanted to be
with me like
like in a relationship and like they
just had sex with me and then like
kick me out so i'm like
like and i have sex with no condoms so
it's like
i'm really putting myself at risk you
know and it's like
so i feel like me trusting people has
definitely changed like i don't trust
people as much
and um usually like if i if guys are not
giving me money i don't i don't even i
just don't talk to them
so
all right casey well thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah you're right
wish you the best of luck i hope you're
careful out there thank you thank you
very much
you